okay guys my name is just and today it
is cinco de mayo so enjoy celebrating it
if you are doing so here's that happened
in video games today Bethesda has
revealed a bunch of new details
surrounding the hardware requirements
for dune to run the game you'll need a
64 bit version of windows seven eight or
ten and intel core i5 2400 or equivalent
at least and an nvidia gtx 670 with two
gigabytes of ram it's 7870 AMD radeon
equivalent or a better card you can
check out the full list of minimum and
recommended specs in our story on games
but others de also revealed that pc and
ps4 users will be able to preload the
shooter beginning 12 a.m. EST on me 11
while xbox one users can already do so
the file size is a bit of a monster pun
partially intended coming in at 50
gigabytes on consoles and forty five
gigabytes on PC the game servers are set
to come online at 12 a.m. local time on
me 13 in the majority of regions but you
can check out the specifics in our story
on site atlas has confirmed that persona
5 is going to launch on sep tember 15 of
this year in Japan unfortunately no
Western date has been revealed as yet
but there is a new trailer for you to
feast your eyes on during a live stream
event today Atlas also revealed an
anniversary edition of persona 5 which
includes an art book the game's
soundtrack and DLC among other things
2016 marks the 20th anniversary of
persona which originally debuted in 1996
according to near gasps a persona anime
series called the daybreakers
finally today somebody wants to speak
out about the way you're being [ __ ] so I
guess it must be Thursday the CEO of
games retail chain game stops full rains
hold a list daily where you will
disappointing to everybody including
them they made some bold birth and maybe
some of them didn't work out but they
had a lot of creativity there they're a
very innovative group of people so we
never count out Nintendo it went on to
praise the strength of Nintendo's I
appear before commenting on the NX same
NX sounds exciting we're looking forward
to it they're very innovative in
everything they do I hope they come out
with something exciting and innovative I
think will be the dominant distributor
of that platform let me know down in
that comment section how you feel about
the way you and be sure to head to
gamespot where we've got stories on an
uncharted for easter egg and ex-con to
dr singh that is everything I got for
you today but to let me know what
mattered to you and join me same time
tomorrow for the top five stories of the
whole week I will see you then